[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMMA JACKSON: Hi, and welcome
to the next in our series of
Women Techmakers for Google
Developers Live coming to you
from Campus London.
I'm Emma Jackson.
I look after Google's education
programs in emerging markets.
MANDY WAITE: And I'm
Mandy Waite.
I'm a Developer Advocate on
the Google cloud platform.
So welcome to Women
Techmakers.
Today we have with us
Lorna Mitchell.
Welcome, Lorna.
It's great to have you here.
Brief introduction of Lorna.
Lorna is an independent web
development consultant, based
in Leeds in the north
of England.
Since her degree in electronic
engineering, her career path
has taken in games development,
database
administration, and a selection
of web-related
roles, after which she took
the plunge and became
self-employed.
These days, Lorna is
a published author.
She delivers training on a
variety of PHP and API-related
topics, is a regular conference
speaker, and works
with a variety of clients
on their web
development and API projects.
Lorna is also an active mentor
with PHP Women--
yay--
and helped found the PHP
Northwest Conference, and now
leads the Joined-in Open
Source Project.
So welcome, Lorna.
LORNA MITCHELL: Thank
you very much.
EMMA JACKSON: So you're
self-employed but still
involved in the technology
space.
Can you tell us a bit about what
you're working on at the
moment and what excites
you about it?
LORNA MITCHELL: Sure.
I think the most exciting thing
about what I do is the
fact that I can work on such
a variety of things.
So it's not just I'm working
on different kinds of
projects, sometimes complicated
data projects for
using lots of sports data,
something about that.
Sometimes content-related
projects.
Sometime something that seems
quite mundane, working on
product databases and exchanging
information between
those systems, but they're
really important to the
businesses that use them.
So it's all quite different.
I also do lots of different
kinds of tasks.
So sometimes I'm training.
Sometimes I get to write code.
It's a real different-- every
day, every day is different.
I just finished writing a book,
so there was a period of
hermit-ness, where I sat quietly
in my office and wrote
a lot of words.
And then this week, I'm out
doing events like this.
I really love the variety.
I can't imagine doing something
where I knew in the
morning what I'd be
doing that day.
MANDY WAITE: That's awesome.
So your degree's in Electronic
and Computer Engineering as
opposed to Computer Science,
which is more traditional.
What attracted you to that
particular subject?
LORNA MITCHELL: At school--
my A levels are in
math and physics.
I prefer the maths.
There's kind of a definite
slant there.
The things that I was interested
in and I was good
at was basically math.
But rather than doing either
maths or computer science at
university, I wanted to go into
engineering, because I
think it's a very
practical topic.
I have engineers in my family,
and I was also-- one of my
best teachers at school
was an engineer.
And I just thought
it was a bit more
practical and hands-on.
I wanted to make lights flash,
and that never gets old.
MANDY WAITE: Awesome.
Did you have any specific career
goals when you started
out on that particular
educational path?
LORNA MITCHELL: Really
not at all.
I had quite good grades at
school, and I really just
wanted to keep studying
and keep finding out
more about the world.
Turns out, an engineering
degree is also
useful in the workplace.
But I didn't have that in
mind when I was 18.
MANDY WAITE: So I guess
one question is--
I'm not completely clear, and
it may be of interest to the
audience is, what's the real
difference between an
electronic and computer
engineering degree than a
computer science degree?
What's the main difference
apart from
the flashing lights?
LORNA MITCHELL: So the
electronics degree gave me a
really good grounding in
hardware, because I was
dealing with bits of wire, and
my soldering's good, and all
those kinds of things.
And I did electromagnetics
and other kind of
quiet hardware-y topics.
I didn't do some of
the traditional
computer science subjects.
So I didn't really take an
algorithms class, or I didn't
write a compiler.
But we wrote code that did
things that solved problems,
and we worked from FPGAs
into machine code.
I learned Assembler.
Then I learned C. I think C's a
high-level language, because
that's the background
that I'm from.
So everything else seems,
oh, this is easy.
You don't even have to
change registers.
So most of the time now I work
in PHP, and that's brilliant.
it just feels so advanced in
relation to my background.
I think having that low-level
understanding of what happens
when you're compiling down to
byte code and the instruction
pipelines informs what I do,
even on a web platform.
MANDY WAITE: I know exactly
where you're coming from
there, about working closer with
them and actually having
a better understanding of how
computers work can actually
help you build systems better
and build applications better,
because you know how to
optimize, particularly
performance is very important.
That's a really great answer.
Thank you.
EMMA JACKSON: I'm interested to
know about your work with
the mentorship program for PHP
Women and how you've had a
mentor and how that has maybe
helped you in your career.
LORNA MITCHELL: Yes.
Being a mentor and having a
mentor I would say have helped
in equal measure.
You think, oh, I need to get a
mentor so that I can progress.
But the PHP Women mentoring
scheme is called Big Sis,
Little Sis.
And I have both a big sis
and some little sises.
They're not all female.
You just have to be called sis
if you want to be one, if you
want to be part of
this scheme.
And I think my little sisters
have taught me at least as
much as my big sis.
My big sis tries to disown me
on a regular basis, because
she thinks I know more
than her now.
But in reality, someone who's
ahead of me on the career path
that I can--
I don't see her very often.
We live in different countries--
but that I can get
in touch and just take her
guidance or ask her advice.
And it might not even be
particularly a technical
thing, has helped enormously,
just someone that will always
listen, even if mostly
she reflects my own
advice back at me.
You always need that person
who's outside of what you're
actually doing.
So she's not someone that
I've worked with.
She's not a colleague.
She's someone that I've
always gone to.
And my little sisters ask
me questions that
really make me think.
And they come to me for advice,
and I've kind of had
to grow up to be an elder to
them, to be their big sis in a
way that I wouldn't have been
pushed to without them.
But being part of the family
tree-- and some of my little
sisters are now big sisters
in their own right--
has been amazing, just this
extra sideline that's really
helped so much in
my development.
EMMA JACKSON: That's great.
MANDY WAITE: Does it take a
particular kind of personality
to benefit from mentorship?
I mean, I've tried it
before in my life.
I'm not very good at taking
advice from people.
I tend to go my own way.
Do you think your personality is
well suited to that kind of
mentorship?
LORNA MITCHELL: I think so.
I mean, I've had little sises
that I don't think I've been
very much help to, and it's
people who don't really know
what they want to get out It.
I think to be mentored, you need
to know what you need,
and I say, I'm worried
about this.
Should I do this or that?
Or would you advise
me to do this?
Or I'm not sure how to approach
this next problem.
Or I don't know how to apply
for this job or write this
conference abstract.
So if you have something--
it's like asking a technical
support question.
So if it's a clear-cut question
where you're asking
someone to give you some advice,
then that makes you
easy to mentor.
And sometimes I adopt people
as kind of stealth mentors.
They didn't really step up for
this, but they're people to
whom I would go for advice
on a particular topic.
And they probably don't even
know that that's how I
consider them.
So I think it's about making
it easy for other
people to help you.
You can gain so much with not
taking up too much of their
time and energy.
EMMA JACKSON: That's good.
This makes me think actually,
so what is the best advice
you've ever been given?
That's a tough question.
I'm sure you've had lots
along the way, but--
LORNA MITCHELL: I've had
a lot of advice.
And I'm famous for giving
a lot of advice as well.
I think some of the best advice
I've had came from
someone I know through the Girl
Geeks dinners in Leeds.
And it's not advice at all.
It's a question.
And we had a conversation
immediately
before I went freelance.
And I literally gave
up my job with
nothing to go to, nothing.
And she said to me,
Lorna, what's the
worst that could happen?
I had a job I was tired of.
I wasn't enjoying what
I was doing.
And she just said what's the
worst that could happen?
And so I've sort of taken that
with me and given that advice
to other people.
Because if you're in a bad
situation, all you can
do is change it.
MANDY WAITE: That's awesome.
I actually have a really
detailed question on that, and
it kind of really answers it.
How difficult a decision
was it?
How far ahead in the future
could you see at the time?
Sometimes it's easier to make
that kind of decision if you
know you have some work
lined up and you can
fall into that work.
But sometimes, it's a
case of just saying,
I'm going to stop.
I'm going to do something
completely different.
That was you then?
LORNA MITCHELL: I really--
it was a step change.
I knew it was coming for quite
a long time, which I hope
won't upset anyone who was
working with me at the time.
I knew it was coming for
quite a long time.
My position was untenable.
I was doing a lot of travel,
and that doesn't suit me.
I'm a home bird.
I was finding the job
very stressful.
And it didn't play
to my strengths.
It's not what I wanted to do.
I resigned my job with some
savings in the bank, a
boyfriend with some income,
and three days
training lined up.
I had one client and three days
of work, nothing more.
MANDY WAITE: But you had the
confidence in your own skills
and abilities to do that.
Did you consult anybody else
who had actually done
something similar in the past?
LORNA MITCHELL: A few people.
I talked to a few people who
run their own businesses.
And I talked to trusted
mentors at the time.
And I think I knew that I could
get a job that was no
worse than the one that I had,
and I saw that I needed to
make a change.
You don't know how a job's going
to work out, but you
take a risk.
I didn't know if I wanted
to take a permanent job.
I didn't know what
I would find.
I didn't know if I would
continue to be freelance.
I'm nearly three years in.
I'm still working for myself.
The right jobs never come along,
and I'm happy doing
what I'm doing.
So it's been a wonderful
lifestyle change in terms of I
can do outreach like this.
I can go to conferences.
I don't need permission.
I can take two months off to
write a book as long as I can
somehow fund the lifestyle
with the consulting and
training work that I am doing.
So it works.
I quite enjoy the balance.
It's a constant juggling act and
hoping that someone will
ring me up with a really
interesting
project, all the time.
Then they do, all in the
same week, of course.
But it's been a real journey,
and I'm not tired of it yet.
MANDY WAITE: That's awesome.
EMMA JACKSON: I was going
to ask you about
writing a book, actually.
Because you talk about writing
code and doing all these
conferences and training
and other things, and
then writing a book.
Are there similarities between
writing code and writing
books, or how do you
see the two?
LORNA MITCHELL: The conference
talks are more similar, I
think, in terms of the way that
you communicate, much
more than writing code.
I've been blogging for years
and years and years.
I'm just about to write my
800th post, which is
ridiculous.
EMMA JACKSON: Another couple
of books in there.
LORNA MITCHELL: Why am
I writing more words?
I should wrap them
up into a book.
No, I've been blogging
for a long time.
And part of that is the way
that I deal with the
information, the way that
I retain things.
Also, we talked already
about mentoring.
The one thing you can't do is
ask the same question twice.
People get tired of
that really fast.
And I'm a bit of a scatterbrain
for detail.
So I blog.
It makes me understand it.
It makes me express it.
And when I Google for things,
it finds my blog.
And that's brilliant,
because I can't
remember having this problem.
But it's explained to me in
words that I understand, and
the paths are all correct
for my system.
So it's just been the most
rewarding habit ever.
And I moved up to
writing longer
articles for other outlets.
When you're writing 3,000-word
magazine articles, you just
write lots of them.
And there you are, you've
got a book.
MANDY WAITE: That's awesome.
It's interesting talking about
programming and development,
and such like, some--
many people that work in the
industry actually see software
development-- the role as a
software developer as just
being all about writing code.
But what does the role of
developer mean to you?
LORNA MITCHELL: The developer
is the craftsman.
We're the facilitators,
and we make something
that's going to be useful.
We're not distracted by--
well, we shouldn't be
distracted by necessarily
the new shiny or
making too many features.
We're closely linked to the
needs of the customer or the
user, and we create useful,
robust things.
It is a very creative,
practical discipline.
And I do quite a lot
of craft as well.
And I always explain it in those
terms, is when I'm doing
something with yarn or with
fabric, I'm making something.
And that process about how the
pieces go together and
planning it out, making sure
you've got everything, is just
like building a software
application, is you're putting
the pieces together to make
something that is more than
the sum of its parts.
MANDY WAITE: That's
really great.
Because we had that similar
conversation earlier about
exactly the same thing, about
creativity, about the whole
thing about development being
a creative process and not
always being immediately obvious
to people that that's
what it's about, actually
a means to an end, just
something on its own.
And I even used the example of
knitting and crochet, that
sort of thing, because it's
the same kind of process.
It's the same kind of inputs.
That's really interesting.
EMMA JACKSON: Can you tell us
about any craft projects
you're working on
at the moment?
LORNA MITCHELL: I've just
finished a blanket for my
friend's new baby.
Most of what I do is crochet.
I'm currently taking an online
bag sewing class from Craftsy,
which is really interesting,
because I'm starting to do my
own video learning classes.
So to see another discipline and
how they teach their craft
really informs how
I teach mine.
It's a funny crossover.
Also, one of my friends
bought me a new--
it's a Lily Twinkle.
So it's a sewable component.
You sew the chip.
It comes with parts that
you can sew the
conductive thread on to.
And I've got little LEDs that
you sew into things.
And it's preprogrammed.
The chip-- you don't program
it or anything.
It's quite entry level.
And it just twinkles.
So you hang all the lights off
the ends of this thing and put
a little coin cell
battery into it.
So I'm doing the sewing class,
so that I can make something
cute enough that I then want
to put my hardware
electronics into it.
EMMA JACKSON: Wow, we
should have asked
you to bring an example.
LORNA MITCHELL: I haven't
finished it yet.
I'll send you a photo
when I'm done.
MANDY WAITE: And I'll
bring you some of
my hyperbolic crochet.
LORNA MITCHELL: Oh, yeah.
I've seen that with the coral.
And that's really cool.
MANDY WAITE: That's
really great.
I mean, just listening to
this is so fascinating.
So when it comes to software
development, you seem to have
an obviously strong
affinity with PHP.
You work with it.
You blog about it.
You write about it.
You're writing a book currently,
or you just
finished a book, "PHP
Web Services API
for the Modern Web".
Was that a conscious choice
to choose PHP?
Or is it more a case of
you just developed
experience with PHP?
LORNA MITCHELL: Yeah,
not at all.
A lot of open source projects
were written in PHP.
It's free to use everywhere.
It was very easy to
get started with.
And this is going
back a long way.
I met a man at university who
was doing a terribly bad job
of the society website.
And I said I could do better,
and had to ask someone to
teach me the program.
I probably had to back
up my claims.
And we used PHP because it was
free and it was available.
It's going back--
this is 2001.
And there were open source
projects in PHP.
Anyone could do it.
It was a very friendly
language to
dip into as a beginner.
Indeed, I did it as a hobby
for the first few years.
It wasn't my profession
when I graduated.
I had done a bit at university,
and I carried on
doing bits and pieces
as a hobby.
And then, it became my
main role only five
or six years ago.
MANDY WAITE: That
is fantastic.
What about comparing PHP
with other languages?
Have you coded in other
languages as well?
Are you able to compare
and contrast?
LORNA MITCHELL: A
few, not many.
I did C and Java at university,
but those are now,
as you can imagine,
pretty rusty.
I was once a Delphi developer,
but I don't like
to talk about that.
I'm fascinated by all the other
scripting languages.
PHP developers are almost
all polyglot.
So they'll all write some
Python, some Ruby, a little
bit of Note.
I had a patch accepted into a
Note open source project.
And that was quite exciting,
really writing in JavaScript.
But those skills and the ideas
are very transferable.
So I think I quite like PHP.
I now know quite
a lot about it.
I teach certification.
I know more about it than
probably anybody
really needs to.
I like the low barrier
of entry.
Some people are snobby
about bad PHP code.
But for me, if it solves
your problem, then
awesome, get in, do it.
And that's where everyone
starts.
Lots of people in my industry
don't have a degree or don't
have a relevant degree.
There's a lot of art history
degrees around.
And it doesn't matter,
because it's really
about critical thinking.
You don't need to be able to
write a compiler to write
really good PHP application.
So I quite like it.
And newer versions of the
language have some really
awesome features in so we now
have anonymous functions and
name spaces and traits
and things.
So it's starting to look a
bit more enterprise-y.
But it's always true to its
solving the web problem roots.
EMMA JACKSON: So what kind of
cool new things are happening
in technology that you're
excited about at the moment?
LORNA MITCHELL: There's quite
a lot of things going on.
The thing that is really
catching my attention is the
big data movement, looking at
data science and analytics.
For me, I have a huge interest
in mathematics and statistics
as something that I feel I've
always been good at.
But because I understand that,
and I can write code, and I
can communicate with people, I
think those types of things
are really interesting.
As a sole developer,
quite often I don't
have huge data sets.
But that's something that--
personally that's where my
interests lie, and I'd like
to pursue that this year.
MANDY WAITE: Interesting.
So another question that came
up from your bio about
API-related topics.
So much of the work you do
involves APIs of some kind,
using them to integrate with
existing applications in their
APIs or adding APIs to
applications that you develop.
How important is the API in
the modern world, when it
comes in developing
applications, creating
mash-ups and so forth?
LORNA MITCHELL: It's vital.
There are very, very few systems
now which do not need
to talk to any other systems.
And at one time, we used to
export CSV files overnight and
do these batch import jobs.
And that's not good enough
for today's now, always
on kind of a world.
So the APIs are really
important.
And even for simple applications
that are almost
just websites, we're
distributing that content over
so many different platforms.
We can customize the experiences
for apps, for
browsers, for different
kinds of browsers.
And building the business logic
into an API layer and
doing lots and lots of
appropriate presentation is a
very robust way to build
your application.
It allows integration with any
other systems that you need.
And also, I hope--
I believe--
helps to future-proof, because
the next thing that comes
along, we can just bolt in.
They'll be easy hooks, and the
system will already be
designed for that.
So I think it's vitally
important.
I'm seeing very few projects
where the website is built in
a single lump.
I'm seeing multiple layers to
that stack, and I think it's
the way forward.
MANDY WAITE: So you talked
about data in
the previous question.
And you're talking
about APIs there.
And data and APIs, they work
completely together.
But we don't really have a
common set of data yet.
We're working towards
a semantic web,
ontologies and such like.
How do you see that going
in the future?
Do you think we need to have a
shared data model which will
allow all APIs to communicate
together about
objects and so forth?
LORNA MITCHELL: I think the way
that you consume different
pieces of information is
often very bespoke.
I'm not sure how valuable making
them all look the same
really is, because data is
so, so different when you
get down into it.
So standards are always
a good thing.
Always a good thing.
But I'm not sure how much a
unified data structure will
help when all the data
we can represent in
the world is so different.
MANDY WAITE: Have you
heard of Schema.org?
LORNA MITCHELL: Yes.
MANDY WAITE: We have a guy who
works in our office, who
actually curates the
Schema.org site.
He'd be really interested
in your comments.
I think Dan would love to see
you create a model that could
represent every kind of object
in the universe in a certain
way that can be shared amongst
multiple applications.
But I think you're right.
The bespoke is difficult.
We consume data in
different ways.
We need it to be presented to us
in different ways as well.
But maybe it's a something
that we'll move
towards in the future.
LORNA MITCHELL: I think this is
an area that will change so
much over the next few years.
It's a hot topic.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, data
is huge now.
And computing is becoming
a side topic.
It's becoming all
about the data.
EMMA JACKSON: So do you have
plans for the next few years?
You said maybe getting into more
of the big data stuff.
LORNA MITCHELL: Do
I have plans?
I'm not really a plans person.
If I had ever had a plan, I
certainly wouldn't be here.
So it's very much what comes up
and making the most of the
opportunities.
I don't really have a plan.
There's nothing huge on my
road map at the moment.
I'm hoping for some more
data-related projects and also
some time to pursue that
myself, but it's--
I'm self-employed.
June is empty.
It's February now.
So there could be anything
just around the corner.
MANDY WAITE: That's amazing.
I think it's like that for
most of us nowadays, that
nobody knows what we're
going to be working on
in six months time.
These changes are rapid.
LORNA MITCHELL: I like
it that way.
MANDY WAITE: That's great.
Open Source.
You run Joind.in, the open
source community.
Do you want to talk a little bit
about open source and how
you see open source's role
in the modern world?
I come from a background
of open source.
It has changed somewhat.
It has moved much more to be
community driven, much even
more to than it used to be.
It's now a collaborative
effort.
People understand exactly what
the boundaries are when it
comes to open source projects.
So do you want to talk about
open source a bit?
LORNA MITCHELL: Yeah.
Joind.in is a bit of a funny
open source project, because
it actually--
it's always a product.
So it's got a domain name, and
there's a single instance.
There's no reason why
you shouldn't run
your own copy of Joind.in.
It's a tool for collecting
feedback
from speakers at events.
So it's mostly used by open
source events, because we work
on the project and
then we use it.
It was built by the community.
I didn't build it originally.
I just inherited it.
And open source has been so
valuable to me in terms of a
quick start when building
applications, being able to
deliver to clients without a lot
budget, 80% of what they
need, and you just make the rest
and help them with it.
So the idea that we're not all
reinventing the wheel, that
we're all working on the same
wheel, and because it's
software, we can make as many
wheels as we need, I think is
quite magical.
On a very personal note, open
source has made me.
A lot of what I've had to learn,
I've learned because it
was something I wanted to do and
not necessarily at work.
Open source is a fabulous
vehicle for professional
development.
I'm now an open source
project lead.
I didn't intend really
to take that on.
It's just one of those
things that sort of
cropped into my life.
And I had to learn how to lead a
community, how to manage all
the pro requests, how to support
everybody on GitHub,
and so many other
things besides.
And that has pushed my skills
in a way that I
didn't know I needed.
So open source will always mean
that to me, as well as
just the technology.
EMMA JACKSON: Thanks
so much, Lorna.
It's just been great to have
you on Women Techmakers.
MANDY WAITE: Yes, it's
been amazing.
Thank you very much
for coming.
LORNA MITCHELL: My pleasure.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you.